all the way and don't you waste it
Jennifer Lopez is speaking out about the
powerful moment during their Pepsi Super
Bowl 50 for halftime show when her 11
year old daughter Emmy saying let's get
loud from a cage
[Applause]
the 50 year old superstar posted a
behind-the-scenes video to Instagram
showing the moments leading up to our
taking the stage on Sunday along with
the caption only want my girls the
little girls on stage with me and all
over the world to know is how to use
their voices and be proud of everything
they are JLo adds quote we are proud to
recognize that all of us together are
what makes this beautiful country truly
great
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
some believe the cages were meant to
highlight the treatment of some
immigrant children at the us-mexico
border
[Applause]
another latin nod the feathered Puerto
Rico flag coat JLo wore while singing
Bruce Springsteen's born in the USA with
Emmy ET caught up with Lopez's creative
directors Napoleon and Tabitha dumo
ahead of the show-stopping performance
to chat about its significance this of
course means so much to the Latin world
will they have some kind of message
absolutely that's there's one thing that
stayed true and all of our creative
discussions with Jennifer and there's
one part of the show that means a lot to
her and inspiring to the Latin community
and heritage and I think just young
young generation in just in general
[Applause]
[Music]
shakira was also all about celebrating
the Latino community in the US and had
this to say during the pre Superbowl
press conference last Thursday the
Latinos are going through a difficult
time in the u.s. right now and I think
it's very important for us to convey a
message of unity and also to show what
it relevant force the Latin community is
in this country after the epic
performance
Shakira tweeted thank you at JLo for a
night that shows how much Latinos have
to offer
[Applause]
[Music]